I'm going to be talking a lot more about
this in the next few weeks but I want to
sort of get us thinking about this we
are now past the point of no return with
coronavirus in terms of the timing of
the election let me explain what I mean
by that it takes somewhere in the range
of eight to ten weeks to flatten the
case curve if you lock down today right
which means that if Florida Arizona
these states that are imploding if they
did a full lockdown today you would
probably not see the effect of that you
wouldn't see the cases come under
control until October first but in
addition to that deaths lagged by 20
days so if we saw a lockdown today you
wouldn't really see some of these states
get the outbreak under control until
late October okay so when you know that
when you see 15,000 cases a day in
Florida and death records in Florida the
timeline of how the virus works we saw
it in New York we know how long it takes
it means that there will be a huge
coronavirus problem in some of these key
states including Florida which will be
so important for the November election
it's going to be going on in mid-october
in the best case scenario and that's if
states locked down they don't even seem
interested in locking down what that
tells us is Trump can't rely on winning
in November because the virus is under
control just mathematically it's not
going to happen this means they only
have dirty tricks left and Andy Croll
wrote a really good article in Rolling
Stone outlining the techniques that
Republicans and Trump are going to use
to try to win one technique is going to
be using lawsuits to wreak havoc in
February the Trump campaign as Andy
Croll writes and the Republican National
Committee announced they were going to
spend ten million dollars filing voted
voting related lawsuits in 2020 in
Pennsylvania for example they sued the
state government of Pennsylvania and
election boards in every County to ban
the use of secure drop boxes for
submitting take home ballots and they
said that poll Watchers can only serve
in the county where they live which is a
great way to if you have a county with
now two highly engaged population you
would want to bring in poll watchers
from other counties that won't be
allowed it's a great way to allow
intimidation at the ballot box
they're going to be working to block
ballots including ballots submitted by
mail they're going to be working on
intimidating voters they will be
spreading this information they're going
to be working to prevent absentee ballot
expansions altogether and we've seen
Donald Trump doing that for months
already they're going to use bogus fears
of voter fraud to justify whatever they
can get away with so none of these
techniques are new but the point is they
don't have anymore the idea of hey you
know what our strategy will be we'll do
a little voter suppression because we
always do it but we'll also make a case
that we have dealt with the virus and we
fix the economy Trump sort of still
continues to claim that he's dealing
with the virus well but the math of it
shows a different reality and the cases
are going to be raging for eight to ten
weeks in the best case scenario in some
of these states so all they have left
are the dirty tricks I'm going to be
doing much more extensive coverage of
this and my goal is we all need to be
prepared for what they are likely to do
we need to expect what they are going to
do we need to have a plan to fight it we
are going to be talking about how you
can get involved as an election monitor
I mean there are things depending on
state laws that you can actually do and
get involved in but this has to be our
focus now because they're out of actual
policy arguments Trump hasn't even
talked about policy in any way for weeks
other than saying we're gonna do more of
the great stuff in the second term that
I did in the first term even though it
didn't really happen in the first term
and in any case it's the fault of the
coronavirus or Democrats or Obama or a
who Jimmy Carter I mean hopefully I'm
anybody right all they have left their
dirty tricks and that's why this is so
important make sure you're following me
on Twitter at D Pakman for the latest
updates on all of this we're going to
take a quick break and it's just a
beautiful Friday show for you today